(ethereal music)
[Narrator] Paris, without people?
No, this isn't an apocalypse.
This is Paris in China.
Tianducheng is a luxury
real estate development
and a Paris look-a-like
located in Hangzhou, China.
As China became the world's
fastest growing economy,
real estate developments
popped up all over the country,
some modeled from famous western cities.
This Chinese Paris started
construction in 2007.
And while the city is built
to hold 10,000 people,
only 2,000 live there full time
making it feel more like a ghost town.
The lack of people could be linked
to where Tianducheng is located,
surrounded by miles
and miles of farm land.
The Eiffel Tower replica
is about 1/3 the size
of the original and stands surrounded
by copycat French architecture.
And just like the original,
it's a great backdrop for newlyweds
looking for an everlasting memory.
(speaking foreign language)
You know what they say,
imitation is the
sincerest form of flattery.